اصداء الحرب في اوكرانيا تتردد بكثافه في
دابوس الاحتشاد الغربي ضد روسيا كان حاضرا
في اليوم الاول من اعمال النسخه الثالثه
والخمسين للمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في
ذافوس السويسريه
[موسيقى]
وقد فرضنا عقوبه الاكثر صرامه على اقتصاد
الروسي لن يتمكن الرسول من الافلات من
العقاب
لا يتعلق باداره ازمه كما قال رئيس
الوزراء السويدي لكنه يتعلق بمعركه من اجل
الديمقراطيه والكرامه مؤكدا ان انتصار
اوكرانيا امر وجودي بالنسبه لاوروبا
وللعالم برمته يغلب على حلفاء اوكرانيا
منذ بدء الحرب هاجس اقدام روسيا على تكرار
التجربه في دوله اخرى ويرون الطريقه نحو
ذلك سهلا انهم عجزوا عن التصدي لروسيا في
هذه الحرب كما قال للجزيره رئيس مقدونيا
الشماليه
اذا فشلنا هذه المره في التصدي لنظام
بوتين فلن تكون اوكرانيا اخر دوله يحاول
احتلالها
الوعيد الاوروبي ضد روسيا وخاصه في مجال
العقوبات لم تتجاهله موسكو التي اكدت
الخارجيه فيها انها سترد بالشكل والتوقيت
المناسبين على اي قرارات او تصرفات غربيه
ضدها متهمه الاتحاد الاوروبيه بمواصله
الضغط على روسيا عبر تبني حزمه العقوبات
التاسعه وهي حزمه دخلت حيز التنفيذ قبل
شهر وتشمل تجميده اصول وحضر سفر بحق 141
شخصا وتسعه واربعين كيانا روسيا جديدا قال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن يوم الثلاثاء
ان العقوبات المفروضه على بلاده ساهمت في
رفع اسعار الوقود عالميا وجه الضربه خطيره
ضد الاقتصاد العالمي باكمله
وسط اجواء الحرب والانعكاساتها المشحونه
سياسيا لا تغيب لقاءات هنا او هناك بين
الفرقاء الناطق باسم الكرملاند متري بسكوف
لم يستبعد امكانيه لقاء جديد بين رئيسي
لاستخبارات الروسي والامريكي معتبرا ان
حوارا مماثلا قد يكون مفيدا اي ان السيجال
الروسيه الغربي لا يلغي بالمطلق فرص
التقاء رغم الاحتقان المتبادل